welcome to the across the spoiler verse
podcast welcome to the across the
Spoilers Podcast welcome to the across
the spoil podcast we're doing it because
we're talking about the Echo trailer and
there's an echo in here Greg how's it
going you
summer going going going
well hey we have a laugh at the channel
it will never get annoying people will
love it they'll eat it up they'll be so
delighted how was your weekend very good
Greg but I don't know if you realized
last week we were talking about the
Marvel stuff and then just before we
released the podcast there was a big
article dropped about variety that we're
going to be covering very very shortly
in this episode kind of feel quite lucky
actually because since then it's been
debunked by a lot of different sources
um but fear not guys we're going to be
going through that we're going to be
going through the Echo trailer we're
going to be going through everything
that you want to know and also there's
been an HBO executive I think it was the
CEO of HBO he got caught trolling
reviewers with fake burner accounts Greg
very very shocking I tell you what H
Greg we've got lots of stuff to talk
about though but have you had a good
week I've had I have had a good week I
think it's great that that Marvel news
came out the same day we released our
podcast I think it helped us generate
views because people probably thought we
were talking about it that day we were
ahead of the curb though man we were way
ahead of the curb that was actually our
most viewed podcast of all time so thank
you guys for supporting us um but the
Echo trailer Greg I'm gonna just dive
straight into it my reaction beforehand
I was like oh God Echo five episodes
getting released on one day heard
nothing but bad stuff about this series
it's gonna suck watch the trailer and I
tell you what I literally went from
absolutely hating hating Marvel one week
and then saying that and be like Marvel
is the best thing it was like that um
godfa 3 meme when it's like soon as I'm
out they pull me right back in but
really really enjoyed the trailer I
thought the way that they integrated
kingpin's punching as well um and his
kicking and stuff was like and they kind
of integrated that into the score very
well um very very well done I'm hoping
Greg that that's the entire tone for the
series and that I don't want to see
anyone smiling at any point throughout
the entire series and if they do I'm GNA
beat the crap out of them like King Pin
beat the crap out of that guy but very
good trailer I know you reacted to it
what did you think and you and I were
here just one week ago saying this is so
silly that they be releasing this
trailer in the middle of all of this why
are they doing this why are they doing
this and no one's even excited about it
and then this trailer comes
out I was like this [__] is so good this
looks so awesome it's crazy how tone
imagery atmosphere can do a lot we don't
know if the show is actually going to be
good you know obviously we've heard some
behind the scenes drama surrounding it
the releasing all of it at
once it's in January which even though I
don't think the same type of Association
is with television shows as it is with
movies when you hear a movie coming out
in January still kind of feels like are
they why are they just dumbing all of
them when before they were doing a
weekly
release however yeah this felt like the
Kingpin that I missed you know I am part
of that camp that was really
disappointed with the way Kingpin was
ultimately portrayed in Hawkeye and this
brings it back more to the Netflix
Kingpin that I've been craving to see on
screen you get a tad tease of Daredevil
and what I thought was really great
about it what I really give the trailer
lot of credit for is even though it's
called Ekko and a lot of the talk is
about Kingpin it doesn't just feel like
they utilize Kingpin as some like
glorified cameo in the trailer really
seems like that the show will be be so
much about the relationship between
Kingpin and Ekko that he will be a
supporting character in the show even
even if he's not in all the episodes
he'll be in a good amount that's the at
least the impression that the trailer's
given off considering that he's the
voiceover throughout all of it and a
beautiful use of sound design as well
and yeah it's going to be Marvel's first
tvma series to be on Disney plus so I'm
hoping that the violence does ultimately
deliver I'm excited for it I I can't I
can't believe it man I'm genuinely
really genuinely really looking forward
to this I think it's going to be
something really cool in the
representation of the CH Indian Nation
but looks pretty cool as well yeah they
have that shot in the trailer where the
guy gets shot in the neck and
goes you know what I mean definitely
don't to see that um but yeah I think
you're completely right about Kingpin
but even if he's not in it that much I
think when it's a binge it's almost not
as noticeable you know what I mean if
all the episodes are there at once and
you're just kind of watching it in one
go you don't really notice like oh this
character's been teased out for five
episodes and he hasn't shown up until
episode four it's like you know what I
mean it's kind of yeah kind of I don't
know how the math works out only being
teased for five episodes but not showing
up till episode four but we'll move past
that but unfortunately Greg as hyped as
I was um one of the people behind the
show they came out and said something
about how they're changing up ekko's
powers and in case you guys don't know
basically in the comics Ekko is called
Echo because they can see anyone do a
move and copy that move so it Mak some
brilliant a hand-to-hand combat you know
it's sort of the same thing as
Taskmaster where they can mimic people
perfectly and when you have someone like
Daredevil they they can really bring out
the the combat flares in that they have
said that she's actually going to have
magical powers in the series and that
the powers in the comics were kind of
lame and that was kind of when I was
like oh and maybe that's a lot of the
drama behind the scenes and know we had
a similar thing with M Marvel where her
power set was changed up I personally
believe with M Marvel they're actually
going to go back to how she is in the
comics and the whole bangle thing is
kind of sort of a misdirect um it's her
sort of getting used to the abilities of
having the Igan and stuff and then the
reason why they brought up that she has
a mutant Gene is because say those
Bangals get destroyed or something it
it's going to allow her to get the
powers through another means and but
yeah hearing that um I was kind of like
uh but you know I went back rewatched
the trailer again which I rarely do with
trailers if I'm not covering them
thought the tone of it was excellent
really made me feel um like excited for
the show and I know that it's you know
Ekko is not a massive character but I
think the fact that they don't
necessarily have a set fan base for her
they can kind of have more freedom and
like you said it's going to be tvma or I
don't know what that is in the UK it's
just put it on for the kids or don't put
it on for the kids that's basically the
two ratings um so and most and I'm
guessing this will be put on for the
kids because I'm not sitting parenting
I'm I'm busy doing a podcast you you
just entertain yourself I don't care if
you're 18 months old um but yeah look
really really good feeling the whole
tone of it I think if that's the style
they go with for Daredevil Born Again
they're going to nail it and I really
hope that they've kind of reshot the
series because they've seen that they
need to do that tonally you know when
sheal came out and we had that Daredevil
episode sure we enjoyed it but there was
definitely the feeling like well I hope
this isn't the tone they go for with the
main series but seeing this it makes me
confident that they can do it and do it
right so yeah I feel very excited for it
and uh yeah I wish I wish I had the
energy to cover it but what happened
Greg was I I set my alarm for 5:00 a.m.
um I woke about half three and I looked
at my phone and I thought oh well I've
got another hour and a half in bed
waited 10 minutes and was like I'm not
getting back to sleep so I just got up
did Loki you know Invincible was out um
gen V finale as well and I powered
through it and then it we we actually
managed to um we didn't know what time
the Echo trailer was coming out so we
finished the Loki episode 5 video about
9:00 a.m. um and I was like well I can
probably squeeze another video out of
this so the the final trailer video that
you saw on Saturday that was actually
something we worked on on Friday um but
by the time I finished that I think the
Echo trailer still hadn't released yet
and I was just absolutely exhausted and
I just thought going to have to knock it
in and we'll just talk about it on the
podcast I I just thought that like you
didn't cover it due to sexism but you
clarified it so yeah thank God Paul I
feel the next couple of weeks Greg they
were going to get called sexist by
someone somewhere if we say the Marvels
either wasn't good or the reason why
didn't do well at the box office uh but
unfortunately that's the world we live
in we'll try and keep a Nuance take on
things guys sometimes it's difficult or
emotions get in there but um speaking of
emotions getting in there lowkey
viewership it's down sadly um apparently
the viewership dropped to down 39% from
last year so it's basically dropped 40%
which is you know almost half percent um
yeah kind of I'm just sitting thinking
this sucks because loky season 2 is
really good yeah how are you feeling
about it
Greg I'm trying to understand why and uh
thinking about why it might have
dipped because it has I don't think it
has anything to do with the quality get
the show and when thinking about Loki
season 2 one thing that really stands
out to me that I find very interesting
is that you don't need to have watched
everything that comes in between Loki
season 1 and Loki season 2 pertaining to
the conversation of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right so that's really cool and
Loki season 1 was a huge show it was
kind of a phenomenon and if you loved it
then you could just watch Loki season 2
so one part of me is going is it because
the Marvel fan base has been a little
bit diluted have they had lost faith in
the quality of the writing even though
the conversation surrounding season 2
has been great the other part of me has
also been curious as to are people not
tuning in
because that feeling that Marvel has
naturally generated of I have not been
keeping up with the MCU that much so I
feel like I might be a little lost if I
just start Loki season 2 right now when
you don't actually need to do that
because as much as we love our
Standalone and we love that things can
feel contained and the fact that you
don't need to watch season you didn't
even watch everything that came after
season one to follow season two because
it's really just feels like a sequel to
season
one I do I do wonder if there's a lot of
people out there who thought I haven't
been keeping up with the MCU even if
even though I love season 1 so I I'm not
going to watch season two I I have no
idea what it really could be you know I
feel like it probably could be a uh
variety of all of those things because
by all accounts people who are watching
season 2 for the most part seem to
really be enjoying season two you know I
get the comments saying this is boring
and that the Marvel that Marvel's lost
its way but I kind of feel like I get
that on every project to be honest um I
do feel like Marvel have put out far too
much content and I was thinking the
other day say when my kids are you know
getting to the the age where they want
to start watching Marvel maybe in six
years or something thing I think that F
those first three phases were quite easy
to catch up on um but once we hit phase
four I mean there's so many different TV
shows to watch and I think you know
we're obviously invested in it we're
going to watch it but I think you know
you need you need to get people on board
the hype train as well and that's
something that Unfortunately they
haven't managed to do because there's
just so much stuff to catch up on I
think there's not going to be any
newcomers coming into the MCU at this
point I think a lot of people are
already on board of it like and
it's going to be so difficult for
someone who hasn't been on there since I
don't know maybe even Iron Man to get to
get on board with this stuff because
it's like where do I start and then
you've got to work yourself got to work
yourself up to end game and then after
end game it's
like 70 TV episodes that you've got to
watch through um so I think and I think
in general you know of a Time interest
in something just declines naturally so
you have people who are our age maybe
that don't want to keep up with
everything and keep watching it or
they're like wait till the next big
thing you've got no kids coming in to to
check things out and you're kind of
hitting a point where it's as hardcore
people in the middle that you know that
60% left who are going to still keep
watching this stuff all the time um but
I think it is I I don't think it's an
issue with quality in terms of this but
it might be an issue of the things
surrounding it their quality for example
you know say say we make five videos in
a week one of them is really good and
the other four are are middling to
rubbish when that really good video
might not get the views that it should
have because the stuff we're putting out
around it isn't as good and it's not
going to make people want to watch that
one video and it might be a similar sort
of thing with this um but yeah there's
been a lot of drama behind the scenes in
terms of what's happened with variety so
we're going to talk about the main
points in this um like I said a lot of
things have been sort of debunked um but
firstly today very recently um niost has
actually come out and talked about one
of the claims that was made in it which
was that
she stepped away from the Marvels during
their re-shoot and she missed four weeks
of that which is quite unusual on a 250
million dollar movie um but she's
actually come out and said look the
movie got delayed four times I had other
projects I they knew I had to get to you
know other obligations and it just hit a
point where it was kind of like I'm GNA
have to go off and do this and she said
that Marvel knew what they were doing
they knew the the way they wanted to
take the movie and they were able to
just take take the re from there and let
her go off and do it um obviously
there's still been people like that's
not technically debunked because she did
step away for the re-shoot but I think
this reasoning it makes it
understandable why she wasn't there for
the whole thing yeah I think it I mean
she still worked on it remotely and you
could still fulfill a certain Vision you
know on a much smaller scale it it does
immediately make me flash to when Zack
Snider had to direct Ezra Miller for a
sequence in the flash for Zack Snider's
Justice League and he was in uh I
believe I believe they were in the UK
Ezra Miller at the time so he had to
direct it remotely and granted that was
like one sequence for an insert versus
like we got to provide some re-shoot but
yeah this was like several years into it
and I don't think it's as dramatically
intense as people are making it out to
be because I think initially when it
came out it sounded as if uh after they
were done shooting NE Costa like [__]
off and that was the end of that you
know where that wasn't the case like she
was still working on re-shoot after that
but then it came to a certain period
where she had to then continue the final
rounds of re-shoot via remotely and it
wasn't like a yeah Gareth Edwards Tony
Gilroy kind of situation or what
happened on dread you know like a lot of
these stories where the director does
ultimately get fired in someone else
takes over the directing duties you know
it's not a situation of that so yeah I
think it's a little bit blown out of
proportion it's still a tad concerning
but you know we know these movies are so
committee made I wouldn't have even been
surprised on the flip side I don't know
about you I personally wouldn't have
been surprised if she did just bug off
after it was done and then Marvel just
took over we were constantly saying how
the MCU feels so committee made that if
it did come out that yeah no she wasn't
around for the re- shoots and someone
else did it some producer fogy whatever
like yeah it's not a surprise that
sounds like what the MCU might actually
do more often than we realize are you
perturbed by it no not really I mean I
think if if you watch the prev
visualization stuff for endgame
especially that final battle they they
have the these entire movies pretty much
made in previs before they even start
shooting I mean lots of people have
criticized the Russo Brothers for just
basically shooting preis um I I yeah the
article I mean that's kind of a big
thing I think the Marvels at the moment
is kind of sort of easy project to pick
on I'll say because we've we've heard so
many things going on behind the scenes
you know pre- ticket sales are down um
the there's so many things you can pick
up for it and I think variety were kind
of just going after what was an easy to
with that um there's also another you
know the article takes a big focus on
Jonathan majes and it talks about how
there was basically the the Palm Springs
Resort which is when lots of the heads
at Marvel kind of get together and they
discuss what the future is of the
franchise now apparently they did toy
with the idea of getting rid of Jonathan
Mages and bringing in a Villain Like Dr
Doom instead now there are certain I
know we've been saying a lot of this
stuff's been debunked but I I do believe
there are certain parts of this article
that are true and maybe some that have
just been you know over sensationalized
because that's that's what journalism is
they they know they can get certain
points in and then they'll be like well
we'll use some journalistic creativity
to kind of puff up the story but I think
you would be absolutely stupid to think
that at no point have Marvel been like
crap what are we going to do about
Jonathan Majors because you know there's
the potential there for a PR nightmare
especially with the trial beginning to
start soon and I think they might have
looked at other options but whether
that's the case it's difficult to say
Obviously were recording this before the
Loki finale one of the big quotes in the
article was actually talking about how
Marvel's kind of effed if because of the
ly finale because it kind of sets Kang
up for a big thing now Alex Perez um
they've actually come out and debunk
that with along with another couple of
other scoopers um Perez is a very very
you know reliable with Marvel and stuff
but we're GNA see how this plays out um
I was actually thinking they could do Dr
Doom and and one of the big points of
contention I've always had with Secret
Wars is why Kang was the villain in the
first place because look Secret Wars
from the 80s Dr Doom's the villain and
that secret Wars from 2015 Dr Doom's the
villain and that I don't get it would be
like doing let's do Age of Ultron with
Thanos what what you see what I'm saying
it's kind of a bit weird um but in case
you guys don't know basically the the
the villain in secret Wars is the Beyond
or the beyonders which are kind of
Godlike creatures that control
everything at one point in the story Dr
do manages to steal their power and he
becomes like a God himself and then he
he's the real villain of the entire
thing so I was thinking say what they
could do is Kang becomes the beyonder at
some point during Kang Dynasty Dr Doom
then seals his powers boom Secret Wars
let's go baby Dr Doom's now the main
villain and it's true to the source
material so yeah I was thinking about
that um but just the whole thing with
Jonathan majes the Marvel have obviously
not made a decision yet because they
haven't released anything publicly and
they're very much keeping things close
to the chest seeing how this plays out
but how do you think is best to navigate
this this situation with him and do you
think they'll do any drastic changes
like that and do you kind of hope they
bring in Dr Doom questions need answers
Greg dude of course I hope they bring in
Dr Doom it does seem a little odd to do
Secret Wars without Dr Doom we got the
Fantastic 4 being introduced seemed they
seem poised for an opportunity to
finally introduce the guy and a lot of
this Variety
article you know we a lot of people are
like trying to like debunk certain
things or see what is and there's some
stuff that I have a hard time believing
but when when when a lot of this really
comes down to they had a conversation
not a not like we've made a decision but
they've had a conversation of course
they've had a conversation why wouldn't
they have a conversation I hope they
have a conversation I hope they explore
options why wouldn't you in a situation
like this when you have a actor in a
particular situation that can be very
problematic for your full franchise when
so much hinges on this yeah it makes
sense to me that they would at least
consider it I I don't think they should
make any decisions until after the trial
is done I think we've seen it plenty of
times now with celebrities where Studios
have made decisions based off of you
know stuff they're seeing on Twitter or
what Current public reception is to
things prior to letting a trial play out
or or letting all the evidence come to
light so I think before they make any
decision on Jonathan Majors let the
trial play out and if he's found guilty
then you really got to make a decision
and it seems like what the decision
would be probably be an obvious one at
that point uh if he's found not guilty
then still proceed like how's the public
going to feel about it but that's all
things to consider later on down the
road I think I think what's difficult
with Marvel though is he's getting set
up as the big main villain of the next
phase or this phase that we're in
actually so he's going to be in so many
different projects that they're all
going to be shooting at the moment that
are going to release after the trial and
it kind of hits a point where it's like
can they go back and reshoot all this
now obviously Ezra Miller is another
person who sort of similar situation
public perception wise you know they're
in a big superhero movie it's kind of
balanced on their shoulders and there
was a time definitely during the flash
where a lot of the talk was reshoot it
just reshoot it I I I do feel that they
have to almost make a decision very very
soon because it's not just the case of
one movie where if he gets found guilty
it's going to affect that it's going to
be a lot of different projects and if he
does get found guilty that you know it's
it's going to cause issues now obviously
innocent until proven guilty but I I can
see at least why there would be
conversations about we need a backup
plan in case stuff happens well is how
much I don't think a lot has actually
been shot for the future for for keny I
I know that there's probably things
written down I know there's things that
are uh considered of where an appearance
has to go and and whatnot and the
strategy of that I think what what's
mainly going to be involved in is
rewriting and rest strategizing versus
having to re-shoot because I think most
of what he's it's probably all in Loki
season 2 I mean at least looking at the
upcoming projects with things that are
film like I don't think he's going to be
in Captain America maybe he has a cameo
in Deadpool 3 uh beyond that I I can't
really see something where yeah for sure
Kang is going to appear in this and then
the question becomes like even without
Jonathan Majors you know when thinking
about the Loki season 2 viewership and I
be I'd really be curious to see what the
comments on this video have to say about
why the Loki season 2 viewership dipped
because we remember how when Loki season
1 ended and Jonathan Majors was
introduced as he who remains and it
created this big conversation about what
the MCU is going to unfold into and the
the craziness that's about to come our
way and nothing really became of it and
then Jonathan Majors didn't return until
Atman and the was quantum Mania while
there is a debate where some people re
like he gives a great performance but a
lot of people even folks like you and I
who thought he was the best part of that
movie still the way he ultimately gets
defeated in that did not leave us as
excited for King as we would like to be
some people really defend it that's fine
if you feel that way totally respect it
uh personally I am on the on the camp I
was like yep wasn't a fan of the way he
ultimately went down in that movie and
that does again kind of dilute your
anticipation and excitement for King the
Conqueror in general when he keeps
showing up and keeps getting AED you
know and and then Loki season 2 The a
lot of the promotion for that while not
featuring Jonathan Majors significantly
on camera in the trailers there was an
emphasis on King the Conqueror again
again and maybe the hype for just King
the character has gone down now and
people are not as intrigued by him
anymore because there was that piece in
the Variety article that did say they
were considering you know maybe R
strategizing before any of this stuff
with Jonathan Major's arrest came to
light and I could believe that part of
the conversation granted yeah I think
that's [__] yeah the part of me that
I think it was annoying if they did
consider it if they were like oh quantam
Mania underperformed maybe people don't
care about King I'm like well that's a
big problem with Marvel then if if that
is a real conversation you're having I'm
like well you don't you should be making
a good Ant-Man movie you shouldn't be
pinging all your bets on uh hyping up
King in your Ant-Man movie you should be
focused on your film and that's where
Marvel's problems that's an even bigger
Marvel problem at that point if I not
focusing on just making a great Ant-Man
movie by by trying to like let's let's
gauge the audience and what they think
about K on this one so yeah I think I
think that this is a very convoluted
mess but well I agree with you I do
agree that they have to make a decision
probably before this trial wraps up
because the trial can last a while
longer so I guess they have to see how
it's
progressing and like what and have to
anticipate the outcome I think the issue
with Kang is that there's so many
versions of him that if you start
killing them all off every time we meet
one it kind of makes the threat less
severe because it's like well ant-man's
beaten him you know he got killed during
Loki season 2 Sylvie killed one of them
whereas and this is another thing that
Marvel kind of changed for the MCU K
wasn't really a multiversal character
almost he kind he had different versions
of himself but he was always a time
traveler and going back in time that's
what created the the alternate versions
of him whereas here it's like no he
exists in all different realities and
stuff like that and they kind of have
changed Kang a bit you know he wasn't
always multiversal it was more time
traveling he'd pop up at certain points
throughout time and change things um
whereas he was kind of more of a
threaten that because it was like he
could go back in time and change
something in the past that would
massively alter the future and he could
invade certain parts of time and change
history and stuff whereas now it's kind
of like well he's he fights through the
Multiverse wiping out timeline so that
there is a different side to it um but
yeah I I personally believe the whole
thing of we were thinking of recasting
him after quantum Mania or going in a
different direction sorry I think that's
probably [__] and I think that's
kind of if they do get rid of him it'll
be like well we we didn't do that if
this article is indeed true which again
it might not be and one of the big
points of contention that's actually
come out and they've said that it's not
true is the whole thing with the blade
movie where God yeah I'm sure you guys
have seen you know it was um they were
talking about how blade was one version
of the script he was the fourth lead in
the film and it was going to be a female
film about life lessons or something um
one of the writers actually came out and
they basically said so this so this was
the most recent wrer they they said um
Michael starberry we basically had all
this info um compiled by our our guy Mo
from streamer who kind of put this all
together but he's outright denied this
and said that he's never seen a version
where the script was this um and yeah it
does sound kind of weird cuz that sounds
like some South Park Panda verse [__]
honestly yeah it literally was the the
panda verse and that was like the
perfect meeme for it and but Maha Ali he
looks like blade he sounds like blade
yeah he acts like blade two-time Oscar
winner he's basically blade I don't get
why there was ever like we're going to
make a movie about blade we've got the
perfect guy for it but it's going to be
about women so personally I I don't know
how much legitimacy there is to that it
might be the case but yeah for the for
one of the most recent writers to come
out and say that's not true I mean veriy
y you don't know I just I don't care how
much Progressive pandering Disney can do
I I have the hardest
time I I genuinely have the hardest time
believing that that version of that
script existed it it seems just so
farfetched way too far-fetched for me to
believe that they had someone take the
time to actually write that cuz you
don't cook that out in a day you know
that takes time to put put a screenplay
together and I have the hardest time
believing that Kevin feige was there
going yeah this is the direction we need
to take I I don't believe it that sounds
like some crazy to be fair though there
were lots of rumors last year that it
was going to be Blade's daughter it was
going to be focused on her blade da
we'll call her but um you know this
that's how these rumors spread you know
that's how they pick stuff up yeah we we
don't know we're probably never going to
see that movie um there's a big sung and
dance on that moment saying that blades
are rated officially but I'm sure they
announced that last year because I'm
sure that was in the Hollywood report
last year but you see how these stories
just come up up and over again yeah um
but yeah that that was the big that's
probably the story with the biggest
contention along with what's happening
with the marbles and stuff um there was
also a bit that talked about how Robert
Downey Jr and Scarlet Johansson have
been asked back
for uh to basically reprise the roles as
their characters I I believe that's real
I I think that's true but I think that
was always going to be the case with
Secret Wars I think the the older
characters have all been asked to come
back this you know I think Chris Evans
probably going to be back as Captain
America um so I don't know how much of a
big scoop that was uh but yeah that was
kind of another point but yeah very
strange article kind of blew up last
week and then there's been so much
backlash from the the Marvel fans who've
been going over it bit by bit and taking
it all down I do think Blake in order
for them to gain control and a little
bit more of a positive direction for its
behind the scenes crap because it's
regardless like even if I don't believe
this one script development part it's so
obvious this movie has had many
production problems right well it was
released um announced four years ago
exactly we know that there's there's
problems happening with this film
undoubtedly there's a problems and I
think one way to regain a little bit of
positive momentum
would be to make it an R-rated film we
have to just realize that most of us
know blade not from Reading him from the
comics we know him from a R-rated
franchise and that's part of the
excitement of having to come in Deadpool
3 to me is not the exact same thing as
making blade R-rated because that is a
sequel that they are inheriting that is
going to cross over to the MCU this is a
new franchise that they would be
starting in the marel Cinematic Universe
a new film franchise and if they are
willing to honor an our rating for blade
which just seems like it should be
considering the fact that blade became
popular not from the comics blade became
popular because of an R-rated
franchise then they should make it allr
and I think that would definitely gain a
little bit more positive traction for
people even just looking at what
happened with the Echo trailer people
seeing that they kept Kingpin here and
it's has like maybe won't be as RR as in
Netflix shows but it has an R-rated Vibe
about
it that does something for audiences and
I really feel like blade needs to be
R-rated and I think it would help them
rebound some of this conversation man
they should do it they absolutely should
yeah the fact they're willing to do with
Echo I think you know that that's good
for me that that shows they're at least
considering it know like moonnight was a
big one where they were making a big
song and dance about how it was going to
be the gorest most violent MCU thing
you've ever seen and you're watching
is it though kind of
like kind of like a CW fight um but yeah
that that's kind of I believe that I
personally believe the the MCU should be
evolving with its audience you know like
I mentioned before I don't think that
kids are growing up with it because
there's so much stuff to catch up on and
I think the smartest way to go about it
is to
basically grow with the the audience you
know we're getting older we want to see
more mature stuff so why not give more
mature stuff to us comics in general did
that I mean if you look at the bronze
Agee and Silver age they're all kind of
aimed at teens and then when we got into
the 80s that's when stuff really got you
know dark and gritty and grounded but
the audience could handle it at that
point because they'd grown up at and and
followed the comics and they wanted
something more kind of adult for
themselves and since then Comics are are
definitely Comics almost feel like an
adult genre um and there was definitely
a point where it was like oh comics are
for kids but now if you look at the
stories there's definitely that feeling
that you know adults can enjoy them as
well and I think the MCU needs to go in
that direction too and kind of have have
the odd project that that's aimed at
kids and stuff but you know you can
totally like even the start of the MCU
you know that that first Iron Man movie
sure kids could enjoy but it definitely
has a more kind of adult tone to it you
know it's dealing with an arms dealer in
the Middle East and stuff and then
they've kind of went more wacky with
things now speaking of wacky and fun
Greg the Marvels was described asack W
and fun but it hasn't exactly translated
a pre ticket sales and at the moment
apparently according to deadline they're
reportedly pacing behind Black Adam and
the Flash now the the trailer the final
trailer is going to release tonight
during a a sports game in America I
think it's a football game American
football we won't piss off the the
English people who listen to this
channel um but from what I've heard
there's a a well we're releasing this
tomorrow so I can spoil it and you guys
know if I'm right or not Valkyrie is
going to cameo in the trailer but
there's not going to be anything about
the post credit scene um which you guys
watch this channel you probably already
have it spoiled for yourself um so
they're clearly trying to drum up as
much interest as possible you know
things are down to the wire at the
moment um and locally in China
apparently it's going to be um debuting
just ahead of Shazam Fury of the Gods
but it's got a very very low pre-sale
tick Ki so got a very low pre resale
kick ticket kickoff got there in the end
um so yeah Greg why why do you think the
the interest has just been weak and down
is it is it fatigue I feel like I'm GNA
hear the the word fatigue 400 times in
the next week brg what am I going to do
I mean the the trailers don't sell you
there's a lot the trailers are not
really selling you on like it's really
relying
on just to think about it it's really
relying on people who watch the Disney
Plus shows and Captain Marvel was not
that beloved like we just got to face
facts on that there are some who love
and I'm not attacking those who feel
that they loved Captain Marvel uh if you
if you look at reception of the film and
the character didn't exactly generate
the most hype of when are we going to
see Captain Marvel again when are we
going to see this character again it it
plain and simple it just didn't generate
that
conversation uh to the to the heights
that they wanted it to and then Miss
Marvel still did well though it it did
well
very well I'm talking about the
reception in terms of the aftermath and
how it's looked back on now is kind of
yeah that's what yeah that's what I'm
referring to is the emotional
Association and the anticipation of
wanting to see this character again like
I'm looking forward to it sure but then
you know you got Kamala Khan who from uh
Miss Marvel which was a great show but
wasn't a huge show and then in W
division you know you got she's she's
coming back she's cool I love W division
that was a great show uh but her
character was not really much of the
talk for me uh for a lot of us she was
she was someone that we the the drumming
of the conversation was not
really the most prevalent with her and
then the trailers they have a villain
there I think but they're not really
showing you who the villain is there's a
plot that doesn't feel like the clearest
in the trailer like you can decipher it
and you can watch trailer breakdowns and
do your best to understand it I think
but if but I think for like a general
audience member if you're watching that
trailer you're like I don't really know
who the villain is I'm not even sure
what the plot of this movie is you know
like there's a lot in those trailers
that it's a lot of imagery and wackiness
without it being really clear what it is
that makes this different unique and
what is this really about you know uh
because I I I I had to like look up
things beforehand before watching the
trailer to understand exactly what the
film is going to ultimately be about as
well and I don't that's a that's just a
theory like I have no real idea why um
this is probably not
doing as well there's also the far
there's also the superhero fatigue part
too yeah there there is the Marvel
fatigue part you know I think there is
that when if something doesn't look
special or unique enough there could be
that don't forget Greg it's a it's a
sequel to secret Invasion as well and uh
everyone seemed to love
that yeah there's there's a lot of
factors of why it's probably not gonna
perform that well there's a lot I kind
of feel bad for for Zoe Ashton who's
playing Dar Ben in the film because um
she's in a relationship with Tom Heston
and they've both got projects releasing
on Friday did you not know that I they
both got yeah so they' they've both got
MCU projects releasing on Friday because
we've got the the ly finale as well and
I I kind of feel bad if one of them's
crap and everyone's like and one of
them's really good and everyone's
congratulations you know given like oh
well done I saw your MCU project it was
so good and then they turned the other
one like I'm sure yours is great too you
know that's the kind of stuff that
splits up relationships Greg they're
going to be one of them's going to feel
jealous they're going to feel better so
I'm hoping that both do well because I
want to see these two hit the moon if
that's is that a sayyan I don't know but
I want to see them hit the moon we'll
make it a saan now um and I think
obviously you know when it's a female
super hero team even saying female I
feel like I'm kind of you know those
females I feel like I'm I'm turning into
a bit of an Insel just using that word
Greg but you know when there's superhero
teams that are women you you are going
to have some people who the misogyny
conversation's always going to come up
um and that's going to either be used to
deflect or it's going to have legit a
mid points in it that you can kind of
apply to it um you've also got like
Marvel fatigue superhero fatigue that
sort of thing you know every superhero
movie bar Guardians of the Galaxy this
year has underperformed um I I think at
the end of the day though it all just
boils down to a lack of interest and you
know it's even the same with our videos
Greg our podcast last week highest
viewed podcast that we've ever done the
week before it's like 25,000 views you
know what I mean and that's purely down
to how we've probably titled it or done
the thumbnail or it there's ways to
generate interest that make people watch
our videos and this translates to every
single aspect of viewership and life and
just getting people to watch things you
know that there could be the best
program on Netflix bodies for example on
Netflix really really good but its
initial week they didn't really generate
any interest in it because they didn't
Market it you know people go out and see
it and what it's been carried by his
good word of mouth and me telling people
to go and watch it because it's a very
very good time travel story um but yeah
I think it just boils down to lack of
interest and um well you know why why is
logy down because it's there's a lack of
interest you know uh it's just because
you know people just aren't interested
in these characters to the point that
they want to go out and do it and you
can take a terrible movie and people are
interested in it and they'll go see it I
mean we see this time and time again
Five Nights at Freddy's for example we
didn't think that was a good movie you
know on the whole it's getting panned by
critics but the fan base is there
they're interested in seeing it so
they'll go out and see it and that's all
it boils down to Greg is lack of
interest and whether you know the the
movie is good or not we don't know yet
but they haven't sold it as something we
should be interested in now a perfect
case study on this Greg is the first
Captain Marvel movie how did they get us
in in that sandwiched it between
Infinity war and end game sold it as you
have to go and see it people were very
interested in the end of infinity War
they were desperate to know what was
going to happen in endgame their
interest was at an all-time high which
was demonstrated by the endgame opening
weekend box office which was over a
billion dollars just in that opening
weekend insanity and that shows how
interested people were in that so even
little side things people are going to
going to go see it but I think just the
way the the mcu's structured at the
moment there's not that driving force to
get people on board and desperate to go
see it and they're kind of I don't know
they just haven't sold the movie that we
need to care or go see it like I I'm
mt's going to the screening for our
Channel I'm going to probably go see it
maybe next week whereas I'd be there
opening weekend but I'm just like no I
can wait and see see how the reception
is I mean it's been almost three it's
been more several years since um since C
Marvel was last seen right in Avengers
endgame and and it's been don't forget
what if Greg don't forget that what if I
will never forget that after you
reminded me every week I remind you and
you forget about it and it's been almost
three years since we met Monaco Rambo in
in Wanda vision and I and you know
thinking back on it now I I take some of
it back what I just said like a few
minutes ago that there was an interest
in who she was becoming in in in W
Vision right but that was like three
years ago almost three years ago and a
lot of other properties have come out
since then you know and this and this is
the problem when you oversaturate the
Marvel Brand when when you're doing too
many things that you kind of forget
about some stuff and you lose interest
in the follow-ups of things because like
Loki's been the reoccurring subject
throughout this whole conversation and
Loki season 1 man I could really go back
to that time and it was it was such a
phenomenon and to see the viewership dip
I was like w billion other things have
come out since then and maybe a lot of
people just don't give a [__] anymore to
to see the followup to it for a variety
of reasons and thinking about the
Marvels like it's it's probably coming
out a little too late honestly you know
for for this mashup like we've only seen
Monica am I wrong about that have we
seen Monica Rambo in other things after
W division is there something I'm
forgetting I feel like there might have
been a post credit scene no sorry no
there wasn't I'm trying it's because
I've watched that that post credit scene
so many times you know for for one
division it's um because when we were
talking about secret Invasion I kept I
kept using that over and over again no
I'm pretty sure she hasn't no she hasn't
I've just checked uh Google no not being
in
it yeah just been it's too long of a
wait to
really cuz now I'm like jogging my
memory about her and and yeah it's been
a long time since Carol ders and and
like Kamala KH yeah it's a bummer man
it's a bummer what I'm hoping for for
this movie what I'm really hoping for uh
on my optimistic side is it seems likely
that it's not going to have a good
opening weekend I'm hoping that people
love it enough where Word of Mouth can
be strong on it that it this is really
optimistic that it could you know
generate some good box office revenue
and and change the conversation around
it it's been a while since we''ve had a
film like that where it underperforms
opening weekend but people love it so
much that it ends up killing it at the
box office for the next few weeks and it
would be cool to see that happen for
this film because at the end of the day
it does seem like there's a lot of
passion that was put into it and the
performers I really like I said I love
Aman volani I think she's one of the
best cast actors in all of the MCU so uh
that's my main my main try for wanting
to do well is I really want her to just
get bolstered up a little bit more I
don't really like she deserves it I
think she does I a big comic book fan as
well yeah um now I know there's the the
whole audience split on it as well um
interestingly I was looking at the
demographics for the first Captain
Marvel's movie and Captain Marvel's
idiot over here um it was mainly men who
went out to see it actually whereas I
feel like this film they've kind of
marketed it more towards women and
believe they've tried to you know Barbie
massive movie they've obviously tried to
do that but you know we talked about
this last week barie is a kid like a
kids toy that girls grew up with and
that is a staple of pretty much most
girls childhood you know what I mean
they all had Barbies I had a sister she
had about 20 different Barbies all the
time um whereas you know that my sister
didn't have any Captain Marvel figures
didn't have Miz Marvel didn't have
Photon ones and I feel like that movie
especially for women was always going to
do well because it's like something that
they all grew up with whereas the the
Marvels they've tried to Market it like
that but it's like who are you you know
what I mean it's my wife my wife we went
to the cinema last week and we were
sitting and my wife was like I really
want a chick flick I would really want
to see a chick flick and I went oh well
the Marvel is coming out and she's like
oh that just seems more like a superhero
movie and it it's kind of in this weird
place where it is you know it's being p
push towards women but I don't
necessarily know that women
are are even receiving that message and
understanding that it's for them and on
the other side of this I think men are
kind of feeling like oh well maybe this
isn't for me you know what I
mean it's in a weird place marketing
wise and I know it's got Samu L Jackson
and stuff but he's not really being
pushed and it's kind of who's your
demographic here now Marvel Comics
they've always skewed male um and I
think they've kind of forgot that almost
a lot of the time in in kind of pushing
this now I'm not saying that they
shouldn't push this stuff please don't
take my words out of context and thing
I'm saying that you know it's a boys
club Only obviously you know this stuff
should be accessible to a lot of people
um but it just kind of feels like
they've almost lost the way on on who to
Market it to because Marvel is such a
brand associated with men that if a even
if a Marvel project comes out that's for
women they don't necessarily associate
that you know what I mean it's kind of
I'm trying to think of like like action
man imagine if they came out with action
man but they were like it's for women I
don't know if women would necessarily
instantly associate with that and and
want to do it um so I hope I've made my
point to syn there enough yeah it's just
it's just a weird thing that I think
always boils down to lack of interest
and I think no matter what kind of
things you throw at it whether it's like
we're in a pandemic or you know
Spider-Man know home show that even in
like a really bad week of the pandemic
people will go out and put their health
at risk to see that movie willing to
yeah yeah same thing when it's like oh
well the weather's really bad so we
people didn't go out for that reason I
think when the weather's bad people will
go out and see that movie and I think
you know when it's an MCU movie if
people feel like they need to see it
they will move Heaven and Earth to go
and see that film um like the amount of
people that take days off work to to go
see a Marvel movie you know what I mean
even work can't get even money can't get
in the way it's like I needed to just
take a day out to watch this movie and I
don't feel like that that's necessarily
there with the Marvels um hope it does
well you know it's better for us if it
does because we we get more views and
pays the bills and stuff um but yeah
just a very strange time in general for
the the genre it's a weird time for DC
to be rebooting as well because it's
kind of like by the time you you bring
things back around is the the superhero
interest going to be killed you know
what I mean I there will always be those
kind
of those characters that constantly have
a fan base for example
Batman um Spider-Man but even even stuff
like we talked about before with the
kids kind of not getting into this stuff
because it's so inaccessible to them
because of how much stuff they've got to
got to watch out for for example Batman
there's like a reboot of him pretty much
every 10 years you know same with James
Bond you know you have your 60s Batman
89 Batman man that has its own franchise
thing and then it dies off and then
Nolan reboots it with his Trilogy and
then that kind of that finishes and then
you get Snider's version and there's
these jumping on points for for new
people to come on board whereas the MCU
where is the jumping on point for new
people you know what I mean it it's like
where should I start with the MCU Iron
Man from 2008 and then you've got to
watch all this stuff whereas if you go
to someone like where should I start
with the the DCU oh yeah man of steel
and then watch Batman be Superman and
you're instantly caught up to it whereas
here it's kind of like it's it's
difficult to kind of convince people
they need to get on board this stuff
well it they they've released so much
too that it doesn't even give time to
get a new audience member you know
Doctor Who is one of the longest lasting
franchises ever now I've never seen
classic who I've seen all of Doctor Who
starting from the eckl uh debut when it
got like the official reboot but even
then like when I started it was kind of
a daunting Prospect but because they're
not releasing a doctor who thing every
three months it gave me time to catch up
to it to now where they have the
whatever anniversary specials coming out
uh at the end of this month I'm like oh
my God I'm actually caught up with
Doctor Who I can I can enjoy this with
the rest of the world now a and the MCU
does not a lot that time just let like
newcomers come in because
so
often yeah James Bond I think is the
perfect example I was actually thinking
today and I put this out as a tweet how
many franchises are there that you can
think of where they've pretty much
replaced most of the core cast and
they've still they've still remained as
popular and as well-loved as they
originally were I think Star Wars
definitely when it did the prequels and
stuff they you know I say as well loved
obviously the prequels at the time were
hated but they've kind of gained a fan
base now where people appreciate them a
lot more um but the the ones that
constantly came up for example like your
Jurassic Park they did a they did a
reboot with Jurassic world you know what
I mean um people were mentioning Doctor
Who obviously and there were also lots
of replies about James Bond and I feel
there's very much these reboot points in
those where it's like right new fans
come on board at this point when they
get a new actor in and they kind of rest
stylize everything and at the moment the
MCU hasn't got that whether it does it
with Secret Wars we're going to have to
see but I feel that they need to do that
to survive because we're kind of hitting
the point now where it's like yeah we're
still on board but but we're kind of
obligated to be on board at this point
because we've been with it for so long
um and yeah it's kind of kind of all
over the even Game of Thrones or
something you know that there'll be
people who W who watched House of the
Dragon who haven't I know them as well
that didn't go back and rewatch all of
Game of Thrones they just saw as like oh
there's a new point this Show's really
popular I can jump B with House of the
dragon and not have to worry too much
well I I think too I mean to the point
that you were making
earlier the MCU seems a little bit
afraid to grow with its audience you if
you do too much of the same kind of
structure or Vibe for so long I think
that's why when they they're doing
things that feel more mature whether
it's venturing into something that feels
a little darker like Loki season 2 or a
more mature trailer like Ekko uh you
know when they do things like that it's
because it's it's been around for 10
years a lot of the audience is growing
more than 10 years now it's it's they're
growing up with this and it seems like
they get it's a hodgepodge where they
sometimes you think they're getting more
mature and then other times it seems
like they're getting more disi than ever
before and I I think that they have to
be Embrace growing up with the audience
and understand that even Bond had to
mature like bringing up Bond you know
even they decided to go for like their
grittiest version with Daniel Craig and
that ended up ping out very very well
for them and delivered some of the most
successful Bond movies of all time and I
think the MCU needs to needs to embrace
that fact as well they they they just
plain and simple have to yeah they they
don't really give room for anticipation
either you know like I said releasing
Loki and Ekko on the same day releasing
the Loki finale in Marvel I I I still
can't get my head around that and every
single person who comes back at it it's
like well it gives us more content to
watch what are you complaining about and
I'm like you don't you really don't get
it like there's a reason why Apple don't
release like five different iPhones on
the same day that are you know you have
to you take the conversation away from
those two projects because you split
what people are talking about we live in
a world of trending and onl online
discourse where that helps to boost the
popularity of something because people
get to talk about it and yeah having
having you two two big projects that you
spent probably half a billion dollars on
combined at least I'd say um do you know
that's budget and then having to Market
it I mean the the budget of the Marvels
is absolutely insane I'm guessing that
Loki's you know in the the $100 million
range so yeah you're looking about half
a million half a billion dollars and and
to put them both out on the same day and
have people having to talk about one you
know having to go somewhere to watch it
while they can't watch it because
they're watching something else which
it's it's just insane um and I I just
can't get my head around it I think you
could have released them at different
points and you'd have all the focus on
that and it just feels like it's almost
kind of like oh we've got another Marvel
thing for you oh we've got it's like
yeah can you just back off mate I need
to I want to just sit down and watch
some Japanese horror mate and you keep
sending all this stuff my way it's just
like when people spam you all the time
like one one thing about being a
YouTuber is there was a point where I
was just releasing like five videos a
day I was like why aren't the views on
this really good and it's like because
you need to give people a break give
people time off me and Canadian lad yeah
we we do very similar videos from time
to time but his feel like special events
you know what I mean because he doesn't
do that many whereas it's with me it's
just like oh it's another heavy spoilers
video [__] them I'm not watching any of
this [__] and that's kind of what I feel
is kind of almost with Marvel right now
it's like oh it's another Marvel project
instead of oh it's a Marvel project you
see what I'm saying yeah yeah you can't
run your movie studio like
a because while Marvel is while there's
like Marvel Studios you can't run your
franchise like just some crazy content
machine you know like you have to have
the feeling of
anticipation and that anticipation does
more for you than anything else and yeah
that's the part of it
where ah yeah I kind of I kind of miss
it I it's kind of crazy to see how used
to it we we we are now we're
just I I don't really anticipate Too
Much Anymore yeah look at I mean
Spider-Man no way home was the perfect
example like even just the anticipation
for the trailer that was insane and
because they were they were just held
off everything and were just trip
feeding us with like one set image a
month and it's like oh my God Spider-Man
no way home was going to be the best
movie ever um and yeah it's kind of that
there's not that time to get excited for
something because it's like expected
almost you know what I mean I doubt
people get that excited to watch soap
operas because they probably offer a
couple of hours where it's like I can't
wait to see what happens tonight but
yeah when you've got so many projects
coming out it's it's difficult to to
maintain that hype in that buzz like we
used to have where it was an event you
know what I mean the year was broken up
until like oh there's a Marvel movie in
two months time I can't wait to see it
so yeah kind of lots of reasons
definitely there um do you think that
when Marvel fails Kevin feig is gonna
create a fake account on go on Twitter
and respond to all the
critics I'm sure FY watches our podcast
and he um he responds every week and
he's like I hate those you guys smell I
can smell you through the screen you
smell crap especially you Paul smell
beautiful though and so yeah lots of uh
big news stories this week HBO executive
has been named in a lawsuit um and
what's basically come out is
that Casey blo um the HBO then president
of original programming he basically
asked his staff to create burner
accounts and go after reviewers who were
slagging off Perry Mason and what it
turned into was him basically uh telling
the staff like look mate this guys wrote
a nasty review can you go on and call
him a wanker or something and there was
lots of weird identity politics with it
for example if you went on the bios of
these fake accounts it was like vegan
proud mother it's like whoa you're
making like really
weird we are great people and we hate
your
review yeah yeah exactly um but he
actually so it's it should be a bigger
story than it is I think personally um
for this head of HBO to be going after
reviewers who didn't like um certain TV
shows um but what he said was he came
out and actually released an apology he
said for those of you who know me you
know that I'm programming executive and
I'm very very passionate about the shows
that we decided to do and the people who
decided to do them and the people who
work them I want the shows to be great
so when you think of that mindset and
then think of 2020 and 2021 I'm working
from home spending an unhealthy amount
of time scrolling through Twitter and I
came with a very very dumb idea to vent
my
frustration then he continued by saying
obviously six tweets over in a a and a
half is not very effective but I do
apologize to people who are mentioned in
the leaked emails and texts it's not
it's not going to be just six there's no
way it's just six tweets mate it's going
to be more than that I'm sure but even
still to think like like Greg we get
loads of crap all the time like loads
and loads of negative comments God I'm
I'm not being hyperbolic here but I
could probably spend every hour of the
day arguing with people nonstop um but
you you just kind of you've you've got
to take it on the chin um or ignore it
and you know sometime you sometimes I'll
read negative comments and I'll be like
oh they're just going at me there
sometimes I'll read them and I'll be
like you know what but they've said
something in there that I can definitely
apply to myself and yeah maybe they you
know sometimes it's just a constructive
comment sometimes they'll they'll say it
in a negative way but it'll have a
constructive point in it and you just
kind of got to be like you know I'm very
lucky You' be doing this thing um take
it on board and just don't argue with
people because I don't want to spend my
day arguing with people in the comments
um but for him to just make burner
accounts and go after people it's
it's like some terminally online
Behavior Greg and like the the guy who
compiled the list before Mo he he was
talking the other week and he was like
oh do you never just respond to comments
and like have fights with people I was
like No And he was like have you not
even gotten your burner accounts and I
screenshotted them my logins where you
can see like all the profiles you have
and it was just my profile on like
Twitter and YouTube and I'm like look
mate you don't want to get into the
whole burner account thing because
you'll get sucked into doing it all day
and responding to every single comment
from your burner account and wasting
your time because this kind of thing
happens and it's just it's a complete
waste of time and he's an absolute idiot
for doing it um and the fact that he
hasn't gotten any trouble for it and can
just apologize it's it's weird man it's
weird I I kind of wish that I'd know
because for years Greg I've been trying
to get a contact for the head of HBO and
all I really had to do was say Mar of
Easttown was [__] and they would have
hit me up you know what I mean I'm kind
of kind of looking back like oh I wish
I'd done that instead but what were your
thoughts on this story bre I mean I
didn't know about it until we were going
to do the podcast it's such a it is a
fascinating story to me it's
incredibly it's it's weird because one
part of me is like it's because we know
so many YouTubers and because ourselves
have I mean I I know you've dealt with a
lot of hate on certain subjects I've
dealt with hate on certain subjects one
very recently where I was hting you up
and I was up all night dealing with
something and I was tempted to respond
to everyone but I didn't respond to
anyone they like put out one tweet about
it and I I let I let it be at that and
um because I've I've definitely had my
Cycles where I go down the path of I
have been arguing with this person I
cannot tell you I've I've gotten into
like I haven't spent hours arguing with
this this one commentator and to and I
can't tell you the name of any of them
none I've I've dedicated so much time in
the past to dealing with this so I'm
like all right I'm I'm I'm more used to
this I know that eventually this will
pass and even though I'm upset now this
feeling of being upset this will also
pass it's such a different scale though
when you're like um Casey Bo and you are
doing like the most petty [__] and
you're having your staff do it it's one
thing when it's like I'm a YouTuber and
uh I just need to get something out of
my system it's still not the healthiest
thing it's still not the greatest thing
I just I don't do burner [__] because
it's more about the mentality aspect of
it of what it's going to do to consume
my mind and what it'll do to my my
emotional well-being and I know what
that exposure does to me but this is a a
a a level of like he is in a completely
different Power position and it's while
sure human it's also very Petty and not
right to do of your employees at the
same time like there's no excuse for
this and I can't imagine it's only six
tweets because I'm like no wait there's
just no way that it could be just six
tweets be like you have too much power
at your disposal and it's kind of hard
to uncover these uh I I can imagine how
much more he probably did on his own
time and yeah it's it's also very
disrespectful to the uh to the critics
as well who they went to go Target
because it is it is an act of like cyber
bullying at that point you know and I
don't I don't agree with it it's one
thing if the critics are because the
critics I'm sure are formulating their
their [__] in a way that is meant to be
a critical analysis you know like like
when you're talk when you're telling me
that sometimes you get a hate comment or
you get certain criticisms and then once
in a while you can actually hear oh
there's there is something there that I
could take away and perhaps make my
Channel or myself a little bit better
when you do something like
this that is that shows like oh you are
not one of those leaders who is willing
to hear criticism to be able to make
your product better and to me I'm like I
don't think someone like that should be
in charge then maybe they have changed
maybe they're a different person now it
was a while ago I understand um but when
I first hear this it sounds really
really bad and not someone who should be
in a leadership position plain and
simple yes so I have seen counter
arguments where it's like movie critics
are [__] go after this fair enough
that's that's a fine opinion to have um
I think where you step over the line
though is when you ask staff to do it
because that's kind of putting pressure
on them to do it because if it's your
boss and you have a job and you you
might be worried about getting fired or
something and the boss says go shred
those um account stuff you know go shred
those pension forms or and also while
you're there set up a fake account on
Twitter and go after this this reviewer
CU he said his show was [__] and I
bloody hate him it just kind of steps
over the line and it's it's pressuring
your staff into doing something that
isn't you know it it could get them in a
lot of trouble um it implicates them in
doing this stuff as well and it's kind
of I don't know it's just such a weird
way to act and very thin skinned it's
not like it would be like me going after
people on a video that you know I know I
know he's the head of HBO but the he
wasn't directly involved with these
shows I imagine like he wasn't he didn't
pour his heart and soul into making
these shows in the same way that an
actual director or an actor would and
they just have them go after people for
for for basically slagging off the pro
it's like if someone wrote a negative
review on trip advisor or something and
you you track them down and it's just
just very very strange what I liken it
too is imagine you're working at a
restaurant and then there there's bad
service and someone writes a Yelp for
yeah and then your manager goes hey
create you my waiter or whatever
whatever my staff create a fake account
on Yelp and go after this person you
know like how messed up with that be I
wouldn't even say it's to that level I
would say it's like you work in a
restaurant where you sell drinks that
are cans of Coca-Cola and someone writes
something nasty about Coca-Cola and then
you get your staff to do that it's like
you're so detached from the product
itself it's almost like why are you why
do you have this complete personal
investment in it I know I know he said
in his apology that he's passionate
about what he puts out which obviously
is because he's making burner accounts
and stuff and but but him to be up at
the top in charge of people it's just
like you you should probably lose your
job mate because you're clearly not like
a good leader for handling this stuff
now I'm sure he regrets it um I'm
probably not getting screeners from HBO
for a while but yeah just a very very
strange thing to do and I think it just
shows you terminally online mate like
there's there's never been a time right
where I've had an argument online with
someone where I've woken up the next day
and not regretted it and often I'll just
delete the tweets because I'm like I'm
so embarrassed at myself for losing my
cool like this yeah like the other week
there was the screen Crush right screen
Crush did a Five Nights at Freddy's
video oh yeah and I went on and the top
comment was like heavy spoilers his [__]
or something and it had like 3,000 likes
and I know it's not Ryan's fault and but
I said to Ryan like oh man I feel really
bad about like I felt quite down about
that I wasn't asking them to delete it
before you guys start never mention
anything like that and I was just
explaining like oh when I seen it it it
got me kind of down um and all day I was
kind of like in the same position you
were was like do I reply do I and then
the next day I just woke up and I wrote
a response saying I'm gonna go Sniper
Wolf and that was it and I just took
kind of made a joke out of it you know
what I mean and I felt a lot better
about myself I don't regret saying I'll
probably get demonetized for threatening
that but I don't regret doing it Greg no
it was quite a funny um thing and the
thing is I think people just get in the
you do right show his yeah I think as
well with the internet people do get so
caught up in just arguing with people
and it h it's happened with me in the
past where I've I've been with my kids
or something and my wife and I've read a
comment or a nasty tweet and I've put my
phone away and it's just played on my
mind and it's kind of robbed me of the
enjoyment that I'm having with them
because I'm constantly thinking like oh
the [__] and I think it's
because it's in your pocket as well that
it's always on you um and it's just kind
of I don't know just yeah just get
offline mate this is but this isn't how
you should be acting with your staff at
all and there should be way more
repercussions for um you know there
should be disciplinary at least I'm not
calling for for someone to get fired I'm
just saying you know should they be in
that position where they're able to tell
people go make a f account and tell this
reviewer the [__] and also make sure you
put vegan in the bio so it looks like I
don't know some kind of activist or
something that because let's be honest
most Hollywood reviewers are probably
left-wing activist people um so maybe if
they see that they'll think they've let
their Community down or something I
don't know um but yeah it's just such a
weird way to go on and yeah guys just in
general the best advice I can give you
if you're online and you're arguing with
someone think has anything good ever
come from winning an argument online and
you know there might be the odd instance
every once in a blue moon but more times
than not guys you're just going to waste
your time look like what's that famous
Jay-Z B where he says people don't argue
with fools because people from a
distance can't tell who is who and I'll
jump on arguments and I'll just think
what a bunch of [__] losers and
there's there's a lot of people in the
political landscape that spend all day
online arguing with people I'll jump on
those threads to read them I'll not
interact with them but I just like
reading an argument you know what I mean
Greg yeah I'll read their arguments and
I just
think just get a life mate just get a
[__] life get the [__] off this now
get a
life so yeah they're with you brother
very
strange yeah so
guys too so we can just hit each other
when I'm reading a Twitter about me at 2
in the morning I got you to talk to
you're in the UK and you're
awake
Paul yeah my I mean Ryan sometimes I'll
talk to him and he just always says I
don't read the comments I just don't
he's like oh you read the comments did
that was what he said to me he was like
you read the comments did you and I was
like yeah I did he's like shouldn't read
the comments because always there'll
always be one comment you guaranteed one
every video there's one comment that
would probably be negative about you and
yeah it's best just to not focus on it I
I give my heart and my thumbs ups and my
replies to people who are nice and
cordial and even if they're criticizing
me you know if they do it in a way where
it's they're not being rude and they're
trying to be respectful I'm going to be
respectful back and be like yeah you
know what you are you are right who who
even on this podcast Greg we'll get
feedback on this and I'll I'll I'll talk
to you and be like look this guy's said
to me and I think they they're quite
legitimate what their point is Little
Mermaid was a good example where we kind
of made tits of ourselves and people
yeah went back at us and it was kind of
like you know oh yeah they they've got a
point let's address this next episode we
didn't say right I'm gonna go into work
tomorrow and I'm going to tell all the
members of staff to make make accounts
to to reply to these people it's just
kind of like mate just get over it yeah
embarrassing but uh are you still going
to send me House of the Dragon season 2
screeners please
please get them screeners I'm just going
to assume every hate comment is someone
creating uh some burner account just to
attack me now what well yeah that that
was another thing that kind of came out
out the back of this which was Gina
Chrono did a big tweet about it talking
about the whole how this isn't this is
not something that this is a one-off she
basically said it's not a one-off and
that Bots and things as part of Studios
can be used to influence lots of other
people and I believe it
full heartedly I totally believe it I
don't even think it's just movies I
think in general you know I think
there's definitely Bots um used across
the board I mean brexit's a big thing
over here and there's always been that
kind of Investigations and stuff around
whether there was Bots used to sway
public opinion and I think you
know it'll be in the political landscape
I'm sure I'm sure it'll be in the movie
landscape and but anything that you want
to make seem popular or or push a
certain narrative I'm sure that Bots are
used in a certain way and but this kind
of confirms it that they do actually
make burner accounts and there might be
a point where lots of things come out
but yeah just I feel bad for anyone
who's sunk that low that they feel they
feel they need to make it because it's
such a [__] dumb thing to do and yeah
it's it's there's no excuse for it
there's no way you can explain like oh
well I got my staff to make burner
accounts because I'm passionate about
this it's like no mate don't be a
[__] [__] next time yeah don't be
a [__] please the advancement of a
IE I I just think it's going to get so
much worse when it comes to these Bots
you know like we're on you go on Amazon
and you could see certain but you're
just like Jesus Christ it's is so
obvious a bot review and and sometimes
on Rotten Tomatoes as well I'm not gonna
I I think a I think I think for the most
part the majority of the audience
reviews are are sincere I think the most
part they are very real and then there
come to times where you see certain
sections where you're like this doesn't
sound like a real person writing this
when you're scrolling we get bot
comments as well so many every time I've
actually got a right I've got a bot who
I think tackles Bots because I'll get
loads of comments from Bots and then
there'll be a person who comments and
replies to all of them saying you're a
bot yeah this is a bot and I'm thinking
are they a bot as well because every
single video they respond to the Bots
but we I try I mean I spend ages trying
to clear out the Bots because they're
normally like sex accounts that are
other people's posts so it looks
legitimate like a legitimate opinion on
the video but what it is is they've got
some scantly clad woman in the thumbnail
and what they hope is that you click
them and subscribe to them and start
interacting with them and I I don't know
how never reply to me every time I click
on it Paul and I never get a response
back really pisses what you say Greg I'm
always like hey I saw you comment you
seem like a lovely human being I'm Greg
what's your name never get a
response oh man that sucks the only ones
I reply
to but yeah so very sad Bots run the
world at the moment um we're all kind of
traveling into the AI world where we
can't tell whether anything's real or
not and yeah it's all fake all fake even
Instagram is like there there was I
remember people on my last work there
were they talked about an app where you
could just get likes given to you so you
you could post could get like 10,000
likes from bot account and it was like
look we're generating loads of publicity
for the product I'm like you're not
really though because these people
aren't going to buy it and when it's all
Stripped Away you're going to realize
that you know you haven't really sold
anything because you've purely been
using Bots and it's not been popular at
all so yeah don't use bot guys use real
people people crave authenticity and
they can very quickly spot when
something's a bot like that bot who
points out bots on my videos so thanks
to that guy um final story we were going
to talk about the Five Nights at Freddy
box office but you know what I don't
feel like I I want to anymore because
Universal blocked my ending explained
and it's like I feel like you're I gave
it a five out of 10 and that I could
easily kick up a storm and be like
they're suppressing me because I gave it
a bad review and Universal or
suppressing critics that give things bad
reviews but honestly I think they're
just [__] and I think even if I'd
given it a good review they would have
probably copyright claimed it because
that's what they tend to do some guy
right he's just sat in his office all
the time working for Universal boss
comes in goes mate what have you done
today you know we're pay you we're
paying you to do work what have you done
have you filled out any copyright claims
today and he goes uh you know I'm on it
now boss and he just see whatever's at
the top of the search for the latest
movie and he just puts a block in
they're
like they're like parking ticket at 10es
they they have to I know this I know
this about claimants they H they have to
file claims
and I feel kind of bad for them because
it's like that's your life you know what
I mean it's like not it's not going to
be a fulfilling job filling in dmca
forms all day um but I wish there was a
way I could contact them and bribe them
and just be like look mate I'll give you
10% of the video profits if you just
leave it the [__] alone you don't have
to do anything just leave it the [__]
alone and then it'll be a big story of
like heavy spoilers pays off Universal
copyright guy to stay top of the search
result
um I did I actually had one waiting for
when they blocked it um it's on about
30,000 well 20,000 views I think look at
me trying to oversell it's on 30,000
views it's about 20,000 views and even
the top comment so I had it unlisted and
then I wrote out a comment saying
apologies for the reupload universal
block the one and I had that pinned and
it was five days later then they blocked
it and I just thought yeah we'll put it
live um so yeah just not talking about
your movie guys just talking about how
much of a [__] Studio you're and
even in the strikes they were they were
talking about how they cut the palm
trees down on protesters so that the the
the sun wouldn't be blocked like what
evil people just constantly just they're
like the worst kind of Corporation out
there um and if any you know I buy a lot
of 4K movies I still buy stuff from um
Universal because they've made good
movies but the people running the studio
probably [__] um but yeah if you
want to make 10% of all my video profits
just to leave me alone know you know who
to hit up not I'm gonna get an email
account now I'm gonna get an email from
like some 14y old in I don't know
Wisconsin or something who's like I'm
I'm head of universal and just send me
the money and I'll stop it from doing it
I'll be like of course I'll send you the
money I TR
yeah it'll be like at universal.com but
the L the L's and I or something um so
yeah Five Nights at Freddy's blocked
video Don't to talk about it they they
harassed me because I gave it a five out
of 10 or something like that but um yeah
speaking of the the deal well the strike
anyway we were hoping that the SAG
strike would end at this point um but
they're apparently getting their final
offer at the moment when this video
releases you know they might have
resolved it or at least come to to
something but yeah it's kind of I don't
think they
will it's yeah it's just dragged on so
long like did you see Zachary Kinto
post sorry you see Zachary Quin Kinto
Kinto Quinto I play Spock NOP American
Horror
Story uh the did he say the sentiment
was basically about you
know yeah they put out you know amptp is
using intimidation factors again and
please know that we will stand behind
you that to not feel pressured to agree
to it just because they were saying this
is their last and final offer I feel
like abtp every offer is their last and
final offer yeah and and it is
intimidation Factor because yeah it's to
get them to succumb but I still think
that they're probably far apart on some
I'd love to be wrong I'd love to come
back here next week and be like I'm 100%
wrong they solved it zag is happy yay
but there's something about the
sentiment that Zach Kinto point out
Grant he's not on the board like you
know like a Fran dresser or something
like that but to put out hey we saw the
statement a PTP please don't just agree
out of pressure we will still hold the
line for as long as we can um yeah as
long as it takes I mean yeah what is the
amtp expect to do like I I don't think
saying we're no longer negotiating works
as a tactic because what you guys going
to do are you just going to not make
movies anymore yeah going to use actors
anymore yeah like what are you gonna do
like you you're kind of beholden to
these people because your industry
relies on them you could get rid of mate
you could get rid of five Studio
Executives from every single production
and I probably would notice when I'm
watching the final film you got rid of
Five actors from the main cast like it
make like who who's the most important
Cog in the wheel of making movies it's
probably you know your writers actors
your directors Studio Executives
probably probably down the bottom mate
you're probably yeah you don't really
you're not essential to making movies
and there's been lots of independent
films that have been made without you
guys that have done very very well so
yeah I don't think the tactic of we're
not goingon to this is our final offer
it's like well is it mate because I'm
not agreeing to it so you better better
go back and come with come up with
something else
mate well we'll see man do you think
it's going to resolve this
week I think I do feel like it has to I
feel like if they just keep saying no I
I would just keep saying no no no and
then eventually the studio will be like
fine yeah whatever yeah I mean it's only
a three it's only a threeyear deal as
well that's a big thing I don't even get
about it why they're dragging the heals
so much it's like three years mate just
agree to it you know see how this stuff
goes and then next next time contracts
roll around be like oh well you know I
know we try to do this thing but it
didn't necessarily work out can we scale
up back or do something different just
it's getting to the point where you just
complet like I don't I really don't see
how Cinemas are going to survive for for
much longer because they they limped
along after the pandemic you now got
this [__] on top of them and yeah it's
very very sad to see yeah yeah well what
are they going to release next year like
they've had so many bombs this year dude
Deadpool 3 is on track to release on
time according to everything they're
saying it's going to come out it's going
to be great visual effects we'll see
we'll save official effect and hopefully
we'll see you guys back next week
because that is the end of the podcast
is it you enjoyed it it is yeah we've
got no more stories what was GNA talk I
did have five nights at Freddy's in but
I've decided we're not going to do it
we're at 90 minutes anyway Greg these
people have they've got lives they've
got [__] to do they've uh they've got to
you know spend they've got to go on the
internet and argue with people Greg and
it's difficult to do that when you're
trying to listen to to a podcast um but
but yeah thank you so much guys for
sticking with us as always and if you
enjoyed the podcast no matter what you
listen to it on yeah would really
appreciate the thumbs up it does make a
difference you know we appreciate the
comments as well I know you guys have
been ragging on how we hate negative
comments but if you write it in a
respectful way got no got no problem
with it it's when it's stuff like it's
when it's stuff like mate your hairstyle
is absolutely [__] and uh your Funko
Pops you're probably a virgin you little
freak I'm like oh yeah that really hurt
me that so please don't please don't do
that please um so yeah lots of love
though thank you guys for sitting with
us for another podcast Greg your final
thoughts I love your Universal Rand
that's my final thought and thank you to
everyone who has been uh watching with
us listening with us because I love the
conversations I get to have with Paul
here and I know I got my loyal haters
here and I'm okay with that I welcome
your engagement because it only helps
the video yeah log in off your Bot
account off your Bot account Ryan
created
it why you can't they use Bots to do
like good in the world you know what I
mean why can't they use them to spread
happiness and joy I don't know and say I
I love your videos if I got a thousand
bot accounts saying I love your videos
I'd be like oh wow what a I feel really
good about myself thank you whoever did
that it would be the movie her all over
again just me love with all these
comments yeah that's what we need but uh
yeah thank you guys again adopt my block
as well thank you for the t-shirt and
I'll see you next time peace everyone